I'm just letting you know
if you stay up super late
every single night
laying in bed
not going to sleep
just to have an extra
hour or two of free time
to watch a show
or do something
that you couldn't
have done
during the day
yeah um apparently
that has a scientific name
scientists call it
bedtime procrastination
apparently it's not normal
to do that
my rationale for doing it
every single night
is because the sooner
I go to bed
the sooner the next day
is gonna start
and the sooner
I'm busy again
but like
I feel like
I haven't had enough
free time in the day
so I end up
staying up late
um
am I the only one
who does this
where are my
sleep procrastination
people at
do you guys
also do this as well